peu
[Musique]
il y a eu 16 ans dimanche dernier 6 août
jour pour jour que naissait l'ère
atomique
il y à 16 ans
[Musique]
c'était en europe le premier était
paisible depuis six ans
pour la première fois ont recommencé à
quitter les villes pour la première fois
depuis six ans les enfants pouvaient
jouer sur les plages de la manche ou de
l'atlantique
[Rires]
à l'autre bout du monde loin de nous
la guerre continuait le japon
militariste n'ayant pas encore scellé
[Musique]
pourtant elle ne trouble guère le
déroulement de la vie rituel en fait
elle était comme tous les ans depuis
mille ans et un petit garçon rillettes à
la vie il y avait parfois des avions au
porteur de mort qui interrompaient mais
pas ici
cette ville et dans une cuvette et ne
présente aucun intérêt stratégique
les causes peuvent jouer tranquillement
le 6 août 1945 claude izzo les
transporte une bombe de 5 tonnes elle
s'appelle little boy
boy petit garçon
quel enfin petite pensée en la regardant
sans doute n'at-il pas le temps de
penser à des enfants
mais à d'étranges d'instruction
[Musique]
ces instructions étaient quand la bombe
se va lâcher ville est complètement de
cap
mettez la plus grande distance possible
entre vous et le point zéro de
l'explosion
en aucun cas le vérifier les effets de
votre type il a lâché little boy
selon les instructions depuis ils ne se
laissent jamais pardonné il est habité
par l'enfer qu'il a déchaîné il a perdu
le sommeil
il a tenté de se suicider trois fois
[Applaudissements]
pour aller en prison
pour expier
il est devenu ce que les psychiatres
appellent pudiquement un inadapté social
atteint de complexe de culpabilité
il
en 15 secondes cent mille personnes ont
été anéanties sans même laisser de
traces cinquante mille autres se sont
noyés dans ce fleuve de flammes où elle
voulait fuir les flammes plus ardente de
la ville un survivant de cette
apocalypse ne l'oublient pas ils ne
l'oublieront jamais
oui
[Musique]
on
ils n'oublieront pas ce cheval irradiés
qui piétinait et achever les blessés
devenu fou et aveugle il était redevenu
sauvage qu'est ce que la sauvagerie
on crut qu'il y avait encore beaucoup de
rescapés des sauveteurs a couru se
dévouait remet pendant les trois jours
qui suivirent 100000 prétendu rescapés
entraînèrent avec eux dans la mort leur
sauveteur irradiés on apprit ainsi que
la bombe atomique ne s'arrêtait pas de
tuer
[Musique]
elle n'avait pas seulement tué deux cent
soixante mille hommes
elle avait littéralement pulvérisé
hommes et objets apportés de son
rayonnement parfois mystérieusement
subsiste une encre indélébile imprimé
sur un mur imprimé sur la chair à
plusieurs kilomètres le souffle de la
bombe
les a marqués
[Musique]
un an plus tard sur ce désert sur ses
ruines sur ses cendres une fleur à
pousser
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seize ans passés hiroshima ressuscita
hopu l'agrandir l'embellir
[Musique]
les urbanistes avait le champ libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pilote claude charlet qui avait
détruit hiroshima est toujours fou mais
cet homme qui marche
hagard dans cette ville moderne est il
sain il marche
hagard nuitées jour il ne reconnaît plus
hiroshima
[Musique]
il se souvient d'hiroshima
restauré hiroshima repeupler joue à
devenir une ville comme les autres avec
en plus un côté centre de pèlerinage ou
de tourisme spécialisée on vient à
visiter de tous les coins du monde
il dit être formidable ce souffle qui
transporta sur 4 km ce bloc de pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ont la photographie sous tous les angles
on se photographie réciproquement pour
les albums de famille
[Musique]
comment se photographient devant la tour
eiffel nous la basilique saint-pierre
[Musique]
ont filmé les quelques ruines encore
conserver on achète à des marchands des
souvenirs des souvenirs de leurs
apocalypse
des bouteilles qui ne sont plus de verre
des pierres qui sont des vers les objets
en changer de matière
[Musique]
oh
face au monde sans sépulture du désert
atomique
un petit cimetière a été épargné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceux des survivants qui viennent d'y
accomplir les rites ancestraux se croit
privilégiées
[Musique]
pourtant leur vie ne peut plus jamais
être normal ce sont les livres du 20ème
siècle
[Musique]
ils sont diminués et rejetée
c'est paria atomiques sont confinés dans
des sortes de bidonvilles
étrangers à la ville il ne leur reste
plus que des métiers qui nous demandent
d'aucun effort
[Musique]
beaucoup ont fui la ville qui les fuyait
remplacés par des nouveaux venus
ceux qui restent
[Musique]
quelques témoins d'hiroshima en parler
d'une lumière fantastique sur la ville
comme tous ceux qui l'ont vu cet homme
ne voit plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ceux là sont hébétés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il agonise depuis 15 ans atteint d'une
maladie nick que certains parmi ceux
même qu'il avait déclenché ni hier
pendant dix ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet homme qui déambulent toute la
journée regard de sa main elle est morte
qu'est ce qu'un homme sans main c'est
avec sa main que sa mère le bercer
[Musique]
c'est avec sa main que son père gravé
c'est avec sa main qu'on écrit
[Musique]
c'est avec ses mains au travail
l'époque actuelle a créé des mains
artificiel pour manier avec précaution
ces petits éléments radioactifs qui
constitue indifféremment bombe de mort
ou cyclotron annonciateur du progrès de
demain
[Musique]
mills atomique
on paye
[Musique]
isotta bombe au co balle contre le
cancer
[Musique]
l'atom fera ce que nous voudrons cet
homme qui ne sait plus que déambuler
sans fin
regarde
[Musique]
il regarde coiffé ses femmes
ces femmes que l'on peut coiffer peuvent
brusquement perdre leurs cheveux par
plaques
on n'est jamais définitivement épargné à
hiroshima
pourtant on a recommencé à vivre
on s'aime on se marie
[Applaudissements]
peut-on se marier sans peur à hiroshima
beaucoup de mariage ressemble assez
mariage posthume auquel les journaux
d'occident consacre des colonnes
attendri les mariages à hiroshima sont
des paris on se marie avec l' angoisse
[Rires]
[Musique]
parfois ils restent stériles parfois
naissent des enfants que sont ces
enfants
que seront les enfants de ces enfants
eux
[Musique]
il vaut mieux ne pas y penser c'est pour
dire
[Musique]
hiroshima est la plus grande ville de
plaisir du japon il y à haïr oshima plus
de cinéma et de night-club que dans
aucune autre ville japonaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
500 nightclub dix fois plus qu'à paris
[Musique]
welcome bienvenus
dominant les plaisirs l'image au néon de
la bombe de mort est devenu élément
d'attraction
oh
[Musique]
le personnel de cette boîte est vêtu en
soldat et présentent les armes aux
clients
[Musique]
les entraîneurs sont habillés en
infirmières elles sont nus sous leur
blues
[Musique]
les infirmières ont du charme dans cette
boîte
il ya beaucoup d'infirmières à hiroshima
parce que les hôpitaux ne désemplissent
pas non qu'ils hébergent les grands
blessés de la bombe
il y as beau temps que ces blessés sont
morts
[Musique]
quentin habitants d'hiroshima se sent
fatigué
il s'allonge il sait que c'est pour
nourrir la moindre lassitude et mortelle
à hiroshima
[Musique]
tous ces malades que nous voyons et est
entré à l'hôpital huit jours avant que
ne soit tourné ces images
ils sont tous morts depuis une
superstition ancestrale veut que le
malade qui a le temps de fabriquer mille
cocottes en papier survivent
[Musique]
aucun de ceux ci n'a eu ce temps
les anciens habitants d'hiroshima
possède obligatoirement un carnet
sanitaire
[Musique]
ils sont tous en kart
l'hôpital fait partie de leur univers
quotidien de l'univers quotidien de
leurs enfants
ces instruments mystérieux qui servent à
détecter la naissance du malheur du mal
incurable n'étonne même plus les enfants
d'hiroshima
encore en 1961 un homme par jour meurent
des suites de la bombe jamais la main de
notre rôdeur ne sera plus vivant jamais
elle ne pourra plus travailler
[Musique]
il
travailler comme ces ouvriers qui ont
construit lire oshima
[Musique]
on aurait fait une ville prospère
ville qui veut être exemplaire
et
[Musique]
chaque jour à hiroshima des défilés
folkloriques proclame en anglais et en
japonais
plus jamais d'hiroshima
[Musique]
non marc hiroshima plus jamais
d'hiroshima
[Musique]
notre rôdeur essaie d'échapper à sa
mémoire
il y a beaucoup de mannequins à
hiroshima du matin au soir on présente
les dernières créations de la mode dans
les prisons
[Musique]
les mannequins ont du succès à hiroshima
et
oui
du succès
[Musique]
m
ceux ci
interdite pendant dix ans
sentant en vitrine
[Musique]
pour l'édification de la jeunesse
la collection des horaires de la bande
[Musique]
le musée du souvenir
le mémorial
[Musique]
des vestiges où leur nombre
où
des objets bizarres comme ces agglomérat
de musique lattes ou de capsule
des curiosités comme ces fragments de
tissus humains scalper par le souffle
il est singulier le rôle de mannequin
dans notre société en voici d'autres on
les installe avec précaution on
constitue une parodie de la famille dans
une maison où on va procéder à un
bombardement atomique pour voir
[Musique]
ces mannequins ne feront pas oublier que
les hommes ont été les premiers cobayes
on continue grâce à eux
à vérifier que la bombe atomique
détruis bien
souffle bien aurait eu le bien
[Musique]
oreste ces expériences ne sont pas
toujours sans risque
elle se propage parfois plus loin que
prévu
ces pêcheurs qui étaient à quelques
milliers de kilomètres
une expérience nucléaire en savent
quelque chose ils sont tous irradiés
leur bateau est irradié
leurs poissons sont irradiées nos
enfants apprendront qu'à l'âge atomique
pour la première fois depuis l'histoire
de l'humanité on a enterré des poissons
à hiroshima on aime beaucoup les petits
poissons comme nous aimons les petits
oiseaux tout enfant même le plus pauvres
à un poisson dans un bocal
il faut qu'ils les péchés lui même la
pêche des petits poissons et le jeu
national des enfants
les hommes peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent tant qu'il y aura des enfants à
hiroshima
ils pêcheront des petits poissons
ils seront joyeux et se souviendront de
leur joie 6
[Musique]
cet homme est le petit garçon
d'hiroshima
[Musique]
dans le rire s'est figé à jamais le 6
août 1945
[Musique]